[Music]
Mike's with us in Houston hey Mike
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hey Mike are you stayin how are you good
to talk to you how can I help
well we got 536,000 yes between house
and properties doing some business loans
and 339,000 managed account mutual funds
mm-hmm I thought I was smart until I
started listening to your show I need to
know should I cash out the mutual funds
and pay off all this debt everything but
the house okay you said it's on property
a house and a business right all right
so break that down for me how much on
your home 58 to 58 okay and how much on
your business okay and how much on the
other property 77 okay so the business
actually has 207 right if I put those
two together right and you have a piece
of ground or something that's 70 on I
take this okay all right and what's your
household income these 70 Oh excellent
well done okay well there's no need to
panic because you have a huge income but
here's the how old are you 14 next month
okay so the shortest distance between
you and a much greater portion of wealth
is to have no payments not to cat not to
keep that pile of cash and so I'm going
to move with my income and with the pile
of money that you have this
non-retirement
the mutual funds you ever non-retirement
right yes sir you managed to count you
said you had three hundred and seven
thousand right yes sir
okay the shortest so if I woke up in
your shoes I said the fastest way I can
become the wealthy
is to continue to manage my income well
and to have no payments at all if you
make turn seventy thousand dollars here
and you have no payments house payment
or anything you don't be so rich it's
gonna be unbelievable you follow me
that's what I'm that's what I'm thinking
my financial adviser has never told me
that yeah yeah but instead you've got a
pile of cash and a pile of debt so
either I wouldn't sell anything you've
described to me because I think it's all
stuff you keep if you have a two hundred
and seventy thousand our income if you
told me at a seventy thousand dollar
income I'm probably starting to sell
some stuff here but like that hundred
acres is probably gone in that case but
you make enough money with that three
fifty to be completely debt-free in what
a year and a half pretty much yeah I
mean you throw a bunch of your income at
the debt and you throw this 350 at it
you're done and you're gonna have two
years anyway right yes what if you had
no payments oh my gosh you're 42 43
years old not a payment in the world
what kind of business is this normal
distribution cool so what's the hundred
acres worth oh gee probably you know
what's your house what's your house
worth last appraisal about 335 okay so
with all of that paid off your net worth
alone there's a half million dollars
right yeah so you know you're well on
your way to being a millionaire with all
that paid off and I'm keeping it all I
don't know I don't see a reason to panic
and sell stuff so what would I do if I
woke up in your shoes probably gonna
change financial advisors because he's
probably not going to think you're
anything but crazy and I'm gonna clean
out that managed account and I'm gonna
pay off some stuff as soon as possible
and I'm probably gonna pay off
everything but your house and then I'm
gonna start working on your house very
very aggressively with any money I can
find above that from income or whatever
is left in that managed account and I
want you completely debt-free in two
years and then you're going to be a
millionaire in four years five years
actually good question